as before we have a red Poisson process
and a green Poisson process we merge
these two processes and we only observe
the merged process here's an interesting
question this is an arrival of the
merged process where did it come from is
it red or is it green we cannot know but
can we tell what is the probability that
it came from the red stream the way to
answer this question is to look at the
table of all the things that can happen
during a little interval around that
particular time in which we've had an
arrival we are told that there was an
arrival at time T or an arrival during
an interval a small interval around time
T this means that we are told that this
event here has happened given this
information what is the conditional
probability that actually this event
here occurred this is just the fraction
of this probability divided by the total
probability of the conditioning event so
the answer is lambda 1 divided by lambda
1 plus lambda 2 does this answer make
sense 1 suppose that lambda 1 and lambda
2 were equal in that case by symmetry
when an arrival comes it should be
equally likely to have come either from
the red or from the green stream and
this is consistent with this answer we
can reason similarly for a slightly
different question you wait until the
case arrival let's say the third arrival
where did that arrival come from well
that gate arrival occurred during a
specific little time interval and
conditioning on it having occurred
during that particular time interval we
can then repeat the reasoning that we
had here and argue that given that we
had an arrival it just happens to be the
third arrival
during that time interval there's going
to be this particular conditional
probability that it came from the red
stream so we obtained the same answer
once more now this arrival came from one
of the two streams with some
probabilities this arrival came from one
of the two streams with some
probabilities does the origin of this
arrival affect or depend on the origin
of that arrival because we have assumed
independence across time for each one of
the processes that we started with and
therefore we also have the same thing
for the merged process whatever has to
do with events during this interval is
independent from anything that has to do
with events in that interval and because
of this one can argue formally but
hopefully this is intuitive enough that
the origin of this arrival and the
origin of that arrival are independent
events and now that we have this
property we can answer questions such as
the following we've had ten arrivals so
far what is the probability that exactly
four out of these ten are read each one
of those arrivals has this probability
of being read the origin of different
arrivals are independent of each other
so essentially we're dealing with ten
Bernoulli trials each of which has two
possible outcomes red or green and is
red with this particular probability
therefore the answer is going to be
given by the binomial probabilities
which is the probability of having four
successes in ten trials and we obtain
lambda one over lambda 1 plus lambda 2
that's the probability of a red to the
number of red arrivals and then the
remaining probability one minus that
which is lambda two over lambda one plus
lambda2 to the remaining power which is
equal to six
so to summarize each one of the arrivals
in the merged process has a certain
probability of being a red arrival or a
green arrival which one of the two is
the case we can think of it as an
outcome of a Bernoulli trial and the
Bernoulli trials associated with
different arrivals are independent of
each other as a consequence of the
independence of Poisson processes across
time